what's up everybody zaki here from geek
culture and this is the battle of the
flagship smartphones the huawei p40 pro
plus versus the samsung galaxy s20 ultra
5g
you guys know what to do roll the thing
[Music]
today we have two amazing flagship
smartphones from huawei and samsung and
they are the huawei p40 pro plus and the
samsung galaxy s20 ultra 5g both
represent the best of each company's
smartphone lineup both are packed with
features and hardware and we're here to
help you make a sense of it all the
samsung s20 ultra needs no introduction
as it is the jewel of samsung's
smartphone lineup
it is an amalgamation of top of the line
hardware thrown on a spec sheet and
transformed into a form first announced
back in march 2020 alongside the p40 and
the p40 pro the diamond of huawei's
flagship series the p40 pro plus is
finally ready for its grand debut
and as huawei's crown jewel in its p
series it also represents the best of
smartphone photography the difference is
also that the p40 pro plus has upgraded
its optical telephoto camera from 5
times to 10 times this brings the p40
pro plus to have a total of 7 camera
modules and aesthetic differences with a
new ceramic back and frame the nanotech
ceramic as huawei calls it is similar to
the ceramic material seen in high-end
wrist watches and even the apple watch
this material has been proven to be more
durable and more scratch resistant than
the s20 ultras glass the ceramic bag
does have a gentle and smooth feel to
the touch it also strikes perfect
balance with look and feel it really
does sell as an elegant and classy
looking phone
[Music]
holding on to these two devices here you
can visibly tell that the s20 ultra is
the bigger device
it's even larger than samsung's own
galaxy note 10 plus
surprisingly despite the p40 pro plus
having a smaller footprint
it still weighs 226 grams which is 6
grams heavier than the physically larger
s20 ultra
though the margin is indeed small this
does give the huawei p40 pro plus a
certain heft when holding it in terms of
design both devices stick to the tried
and tested
curved edges slim profiles with both
offering a firm grip when held in your
hands
we also see both manufacturers improve
on their previous models with a glass
sandwich design and one feature that has
first become a standard a huge camera
bump on the rear folks who are
interested in the huawei p40 pro plus
can either choose from the white or
black version
that being said the white version does
kind of keep your fingerprints out of
the way for the s20 ultra you do get it
in cosmic green or cosmic black and we
would love to see more colored variants
coming from the s20 line like the cloud
blue or cloud pink it is also
unfortunately a fingerprint magnet and
you can expect yourself to see a lot of
smudges at the back of the phone
and the s20 ultras huge
camera bump really protrudes out from
the device especially if you lay on a
flat surface
the s20 ultra takes the cake here for
having one of the most gorgeous looking
displays ever seen on a smartphone
with a resolution of 3200 by 1440 and a
maximum refresh rate of 120 hertz this
6.9 inch amoled panel is something that
samsung would only manufacture for
themselves
it also supports hdr 10 plus with
compatible source material
a quick point to note here is that the
120hz refresh rate only works with 1080p
resolution instead of a full 1440p
the p40 pro plus 6 more balance with its
2640 by 1200 resolution
and 90 hertz refresh rate the p40 pro
plus has a slightly smaller screen
coming in at 6.58 inches
diagonally and on the other hand does
not go to the extreme with its numbers
this decision was probably made with a
consideration that a larger and higher
res screen would take a big hit on
battery life
the high refresh rates on these displays
are very noticeable
and once you do get used to it a regular
60hz display would seem really sluggish
in comparison
moving on to hardware this is a quick
spec rundown of both phones
[Music]
we see the snapdragon 865 or samsung's
own exynos 990 chipset on the s20 ultra
16 gigabytes of ram on the s20 seems to
be overkill for most
but the s20 ultra is not for most people
the extra memory space serves to allow
the user to keep background apps open
for multitasking and there's even an
option to pin up to three apps that
never close in the background
this is really useful for power users
who are working through their
smartphones on the go
in terms of storage capacity
the s20 ultra comes with 128 gigabytes
of internal storage with expandable
memory via microsd up to 1 terabytes
paired with the kirin 990 chipset the
huawei p40 pro plus chugs a lot of speed
even under heavy load while the p40 pro
plus makes do with 8 gigabytes of ram
this should be plenty and more practical
for the regular user the huawei p40 pro
plus packs a punch with an octa-core
processor and the mali g76 graphics unit
handles almost all apps without breaking
a sweat combined with the 90 hertz
display the p40 pro plus gives mobile
gamers an immersive experience when
playing fast-paced games such as asphalt
9 or fortnite while the p40 pro plus
comes with 512 gigabytes of internal
memory and expandable memory via
huawei's proprietary nano memory card up
to 256 gigabytes
now we've come to the most valued and
important feature
100 times space
ultra
vision
leica
penta
camera
the cameras on these phones play a huge
part of their marketing and it's easy to
see why
the p40 pro plus here spots one of the
largest smartphone camera sensors
measuring in at 1 over 1.28 inches
in other words more natural bokeh
the p40 pro plus has a total of 5
cameras on the rear paired with a
time-of-flight sensor the combination of
these five cameras will be able to give
you a focal range from ultra wide to 10
times optical zoom and 50x digital zoom
on the front of the p40 pro plus there
is a single selfie camera and a depth
sensor as well for more secure
biometrics
we also see a pixel binning happening
here on the pe40 pro plus with its 50
megapixel sensor to also produce by
default 12 megapixel images
of course you will be able to turn on
the hi-res mode to obtain the full 50
megapixel image we see huawei's night
mode here as well and they have really
been the ones to pioneer the technology
and implement night mode into smartphone
cameras
this mode of course works best when you
have the phone on a stable platform like
a tripod or a tabletop as how it works
is it essentially takes multiple
exposures of the scene and combines them
together automatically
the video capabilities of the p40 pro
plus hits a maximum of 4k resolution at
60 frames per second from both the rear
and front cameras the optical image
stabilization kicks in when shooting and
it really helps with shaky hands while
shooting while walking
there's also a whole selection of
different camera modes such as
monochrome hdr light painting and even
documents mode which can be used as a
file scanner two of these additional
modes are really interesting
the first would be the dual view mode
which lets you shoot video with both the
standard and telephoto cameras at the
same time
the other will be the super slow motion
mode which can shoot a short video clip
at up to 256 times slower than real life
this can bring about some really
impressive stuff if you are using it
correctly
it is also recommended that this mode be
used with a lot of light as it is
shooting at a really high frame rate
counting the depth sensor on the rear
the s20 ultra sports a total of five
cameras one selfie camera one standard
one ultra wide and one periscope
telephoto
all these specs look really impressive
on paper dissecting each individual
feature we will see that these huge
numbers are mostly marketing gimmicks
now that's not to say that the s20
ultra's photo and video capabilities are
moot
because they are not
as mentioned earlier the samsung sees a
mishmash of the biggest numbers possible
108 megapixels 100 times zoom and 8k
video recording capability a better
analogy will be akin to owning a
supercar which has a max of 300
kilometers per hour
which has a max speed of 300 kilometers
per hour
no you probably won't be driving at that
speed anyway nor is it practical too but
a higher upper limit also means that it
can do everything lower than that more
comfortably compared to say an ordinary
car that can only go 200 kilometers per
hour the rear cameras work together to
give the user a focal range from ultra
wide to five times optical zoom and
digital zoom all the way to 100 times
that being said
the photos from the s20 ultra are great
when shot in good light
with samsung's trademark characteristics
of increased vibrancy and saturation
images are sharp with plenty of details
in lower light conditions
we see digital noise start to creep into
the image significantly due to its high
pixel density while the software will
try its best to denoise the final jpeg
file
sometimes it will end up as a splotchy
mess
however this is something you will see
in all smartphone cameras and it's not
unique to just the s20 ultra
on the front the s20 ultra makes do with
a single 40 megapixel selfie camera
without additional depth sensors it will
produce 10 megapixel images by default
and has a wide enough field of view to
accommodate group selfies
the image quality from the front camera
is rather impressive and there's even an
option to turn off any beauty or skin
smoothening effects here a glaring issue
with the main camera on the s20 ultra is
its autofocus which is surprisingly
inconsistent this was an issue that
plagued the phone upon its launch and
even after multiple firmware updates the
problem has not totally gone away it is
most prominent when either taking photos
of the neural object or doing video
recording where it needs you to
constantly point where to focus at
instead of tracking or changing focus as
the scene changes
comparing these cameras we see that the
huawei p40 pro plus has a longer optical
focal range as compared to the samsung
s20 ultra the p40 pro plus has a focal
range from ultra wide to 10 times
optical zoom which as of this video is
the longest optical zoom range ever seen
on a smartphone this is all thanks to
its ingenious periscope camera
technology which huawei has constantly
been improving on the s20 ultra also
uses the same periscope camera
technology but it has a much shorter
focal range of ultra wide to 4 times
optical zoom a combination of hybrid
zoom and digital zoom takes over to
provide up to 100 times zoom on both
phones
comparing the two
you can clearly see that the longer
optical range of the p40 pro plus gives
it a cleaner and sharper image at ranges
of 5 times and 10 times zoom while the
s20 ultra which only has an optical zoom
of 4 times starts to compensate by
relying on its high megapixel sensor to
edge in details on far away objects
however when it comes to the full 100
times zoom the mighty end of their zoom
ranges results from both phones are
rather muddy and subpar our stand on
this feature is that the 100 times
digital zoom is more of a novelty
feature and a proof of concept
users can also expect to have a lot of
trouble handling the stability at 100
times zoom on both phones and even with
a tripod it's still hard to get the
subject in frame and stable but we do
have to say it's a great party trick and
a conversation starter
the p40 pro plus loses out here on
battery capacity
with a 4200mah battery compared to the
massive 5000 milliamp hour battery in
the s20 ultra these huge capacities are
more or less mandatory to power the
hardware that these bad boys are packing
however in terms of day-to-day usage you
not see a huge difference in battery
life nor will running out of juice ever
be a problem
both of these phones have more than
enough battery life to last you an
entire day
with the higher refresh rate on the s20
ultra there will be a higher drain on
the bigger battery which effectively
cancels out the larger capacity
both of these are ready for fast
charging and the p40 pro plus comes with
a 40 watt fast charger right out of the
box
the s20 ultra unfortunately does not and
the 45 watt fast charger would have to
be purchased separately
wireless fast charging is also enabled
on both devices with 15 watt wireless
charging on the s20 ultra and the
blazing fast 40 watt fast charging
capability on the p40 pro plus
which is already faster than normal
charging solutions
the p40 pro plus and the s20 ultra both
support reverse wireless charging with
the ability to charge other phones and
accessories such as wireless earbuds and
smart watches as long as they support
the qi wireless standards
on-screen fingerprint readers are seen
on both of these phones although they
use different technologies the samsung
sees an ultrasonic reader while the
huawei uses optical technology
however in daily use both of them are
equally quick to unlock the device
face unlock is also available on both
phones
and again the two do it slightly
differently
the huawei has a depth sensor on the
front for more accurate face mapping
while the s20 ultra is still using a
single camera for visual matching
both phones are 5g ready but users will
only enjoy them when 5g networks are
introduced where you live
[Music]
users can definitely expect blazing fast
data speeds once it rolls out both
samsung and huawei are running android
10 with their respective skins over them
samsung's one ui has constantly been
improving from its touchwiz days
but recently it has been relapsing to
incorporate more bloatware into the
system such as its bixby incorporation
and samsung daily huawei's emui 10 is a
rather clean installation of android
sprinkled with a bunch of huawei apps
and some interface additions such as
gestures
huawei has cilia
which is its version of a voice
activated assistant
how useful this will be though remains
to be seen the huawei app gallery has a
decent catalog of apps
including more sensitive apps such as
internet banking and investment apps for
the majority of popular apps such as
facebook whatsapp and telegram you'll
find them on the huawei it's the little
known apps though such as photo editing
apps like photoshop or even games like
call of duty mobile that requires some
effort to install
of course there is also the option of
downloading apk files of the web into
your phone however we wouldn't recommend
it because there is a riskier option
there is a neat built-in phone clone app
which duplicates all your apps from your
existing phone
able to work on both android and ios
phones
with the p40 pro plus huawei has also
launched its very own search tool the
pedal search
it gives users an alternative way of
accessing a wider range of apps from
multiple sources to download on their
phone
according to huawei
the app was created in partnership with
global search engine leaders
and serves to ensure users get the
latest information from aggregated apps
news movies and more
the app is also available and can be
found in the app gallery or installed
together with the latest phone software
update
the elephant in the room is huawei's
lack of access to google services which
is a huge consideration for someone who
is interested in the huawei p40 pro plus
while you are still able to get google
maps from the phone clone app google
chrome from pencil search and gmail via
the native email app folks might still
find this a tad too tedious and
technical
the huawei p40 pro plus and the samsung
s20 ultra are already available for
purchase and both are at identical
prices of
1898 singapore dollars the samsung s20
ultra does offer a little bit more value
and we gotta give props to huawei for
making a smartphone that competes with
samsung's flagship in all grounds so is
the s20 ultra greater than the sum of
all its exaggerated parts it has proof
that you can manufacture a super
smartphone but samsung's track record of
assuming powerful hardware is enough to
create a stellar product still shines
through
with the p40 pro plus huawei has shown
that balance is needed and that they
have towed the line really well the only
downside is that people who are
interested in the p40 pro plus may have
to take extra steps to get the desired
apps that they want but the p40 pro plus
is definitely a smartphone that checks
all the right boxes
well that's the end of the video we hope
you enjoyed it and probably had a better
understanding of what both of these
phones can do and until then this is
zacky from geek culture signing off